[Music]
hi everyone
so the next question is from the footage
we have already seen
aiden seems much less confident and more
nervous than crane
will the game's plot focus on his growth
as a person
the same way the first game focused a
lot on crane and his changing motives
so the answer is yes absolutely this is
what great stories
are about right so aiden is a defined
character when
when the game starts and he has his own
motives and he has his own
like mood and characteristics
and all of those things things impact
how he behaves at the start of the game
but he's also a character that is
searching for identity
and is also searching for a discovery
for a secret from his past
which of course i cannot spoil to you at
this point because i would like you to
discover this
in-game and but the thing is that
as the game progresses the character arc
builds and you have impact over the
character arc
and actually by your decisions you will
be able to
kind of change or decide what
item you will have at the end of the
whole story at the end of the whole
experience
so depending on your choices i then can
be a little bit more selfish
or a little bit more focused on the
collective and the needs of others
and i think this is the most important
thing that you will decide
regarding the character
[Music]
another question and this one is about
gre
so the question is will the gre make a
return
or at least be a player in what led up
to the events in dying lights too
i understand that dl2 is set far in the
future from dl1 but i find it a bit
difficult to imagine how an
organization with enough money and power
to fly in drops and
antis in daily could disappear if the
virus
wasn't wiped out the gre is such an
enormous
organization they left
very many traces in the map
so yes this organization was very
wealthy
very powerful so imagine what can you
find
when looking for those traces
so yes gre is making a return
in dying light 2 and it will play a very
important part in
the overall world building of the game
so you will see plenty of bits and
pieces and collectibles and
notes and references to what happened to
gre
and basically how it connect
how it connects and what role it plays
in the events between
uh dying light one and dying lights too
another thing is that you will also
encounter a lot of
gre related stuff in the game and
actually there will be
even open world activities built around
you
discovering and exploring abundant gre
labs and
quarantine areas so if you are really
interested in the backstory of gre you
will have
a lot of places where you will be able
to learn it
[Music]
the next question is about romance so
the question is
i don't really play games with romans in
them but
in the first line late game jade and
crane had
somewhat of a relationship romantic
relationship going on
so can we expect to see something along
the same lines for dying light too
so for sure you will experience a lot of
very strong
very complex relations between people
between the main character and the npcs
between the npcs themselves
and of course there will be quite a few
very strong
female characters but we don't have
romance options like in bioware games
for example because
this was never our goal
[Music]
okay so the next one is the heavy one
and we have been
asked this basically since we announced
the game
so the question is which ending of the
following
is canonical so it's still a little bit
too early
to say it all to you guys but um
let me just tell you that the events in
dying light 2 and the events that have
led up to dying light 2 are very
strongly connected
to what happened in the first game so
when you play dying light 2 you will
surely
discover the answer to this big question
the story of dying like 2 takes place
several years
after the story of dying light 1. kyle
crane was
such an important person in all the
events that happened in dying light one
so he must have left at least an impact
of what will happen in the english too
[Music]
so this one is actually very interesting
so please listen closely
will it be possible to recreate the
technology and the government
or perhaps people will be doomed to live
in the modern dark ages for a long time
so the question is straight and simple
we don't want to give you an option to
rebuild the government and technology
and community as we know it today why
because to be honest we thought that
would actually be quite boring
we know that stuff there's no point in
rebuilding this
what is more interesting to us is
actually present our own
vision of what the future could be after
an apocalypse like this
so yes you will stay in the modern dark
ages we created
but as has been said uh quite a few
times in this ama
you will be able to shape the future by
your decisions so
you will be able to decide what kind of
buildings what kind of structures what
kind of community
will the place be after you finish the
game
[Music]
there goes another one and this is
another one that we have been asked
since the first e3 when we announced the
game
so the question is will some characters
from dl1 be
returning in this game too or and if so
then can you name a few or maybe it's
confidential
so dying light 2 takes place in a
completely different place
and quite a lot of years after the
events of the first one
so for this reason you will not
encounter any
returning characters from the first game
but of course there will be
quite a lot of references to what
happened in the first game
and also some of the characters so
please
keep a close eye on what what you will
be able to find
and discover in the game
julia could you tell us will there be
more open world events such as the eye
drops from the first game
yes there will be a lot more open world
events in dying light too
not only we will have the living world
with
encounters all over but also you will be
able to explore new locations
such as gre quarantine or dark places
oh this is very very important it's
about the factions in the game so the
question is
what can you say about the main factions
in dying light 2
how do these two groups affect the
entire city so yes there are two main
factions in the
dying light world and it's up to you to
decide
which one of those you want to side with
so the thing about them is that
their strategy to survival differs so
first of all there are the peacekeepers
and these are the strong military types
so they
they they focus mostly on combat they
want to kill all of the infecteds
that are out there so they build
powerful weapons they build powerful
traps
and they work kind of like this military
regime
the other faction is survivors and they
want to
adapt they just want to survive so they
adapt to the environment building their
communities
planting fields and also investing and
focusing on traversal
they don't fight that much they just
want to be able to travel
the city easily and escape and the
threats so if you side with them you
will be
starting more and more of their of their
traversal helpers and you will be able
to use that
as well of course aside from the
peacekeepers and the survivors
there are other groups in the city the
next important one is the renegades
and they are basically the bad guys so
you will face them and you will have to
make some decisions how you want to deal
with them
and then there are also smaller groups
which are used mostly in side quests or
as like additional background characters
for the main quests
colorful people colorful groups with
their own
ideas agendas that you will be able to
discover while you'll be playing dying
light
too
there goes another question and it says
will i be able to side with no factions
and be
an enemy to all so you have to
understand
that our world is extremely brutal
extremely primal and it's full of
threats and conflicts
so if you have no allies you basically
die
very quickly and we don't want you to
die very quickly and we also want you to
make a decision
we also want you to make a statement so
a lone wolf option is not available
you will have to decide if you want to
play with those guys or the other ones